all right so these are uh frequently
asked questions and these are I guess
FAQ FAQ epoch useful the things that
people ask the most how do I become an
astrophysicist cool that's a good
question yet very cool so first you have
to love it okay that's a good answer
because I think I want to be something
that you don't love right that's a
there's a world of hurt right there and
a lot of people growing up want to be
things that their parents wanted them to
be and it doesn't really come from
within rather they want to become a
doctor lawyer but it's not really driven
by their own motivation and they become
adults and they find out that they're
not really happy at the end of the day
right so you gotta move you gotta love
it and then you presumably you're in
school you're going back to school yeah
I take a lot of math right because math
is the language of the universe yes so
now wait let me out putting addendum on
there personally how do you develop or
discover your love of Sciences
particularly physics because I think
that a lot of kids you know myself
included find out very late in life yeah
they love science I've really didn't
come into a love of science until I was
probably out of college to like last
week this morning what time is it what
time is it but how do you some get
cultivate and develop that I was
fortunate because my parents who votes
still alive and they're in their 80s
been married 60 years when I my siblings
were kids they took us around then we
grew up in New York City they took us
around to all of the cultural
institutions that showed adults doing
things that were not your standard
professions that we went to the zoo and
we saw the zookeepers and we went to the
museums and we saw artists and the art
museums and the Museum of Natural
History where you see mammalogists and
you know virologists like ornithologist
bug all ecologist and so you get to see
just all the things you can be when you
grow up and one of those trips I was
nine years old we went to the Hayden
Planetarium oh my god yes and I did not
know that and I'm pretty sure the
universe
told me that I had no say in the matter
because after that first visit I was
hooked
and I so much to the point where you now
run though Hayden I do want you know the
story play well like in in small towns
you know but in the big city you know
the fact that I came back and ran the
planetarium that that started me it
doesn't play as big in a big city as it
would in a small town but yes that's
exactly what happened I'm not direct ER
of the same place that inspired me to a
career science in the first place that's
really cool so here's the thing about
math just to consider this if you know
it if you if you stumble upon a page in
Chinese right and you say I don't
understand if it's not that alphab that
you not nothing on there can you leave
as we grew up knowing English but you're
not saying to yourself I'm too stupid to
learn it you just say I haven't spent
the time and if you spend two weeks
trying to learn it and you still don't
know it are you saying this is
impossible no you know it takes time it
takes years to be fluent in another
language right
I've seen people turned off my math
because they didn't instantly get it in
a couple of weeks or even a couple of
months that's not right give me a chance
all we're saying is it Neil deGrasse
Tyson be John Lennon a math kid F jab
mathachan once you are fluent in math
then the universe becomes transparent to
you okay and the physics becomes that
much more empowering for you to know
because when you look up at the night
sky you don't say yourself I wonder
what's up you say oh that's a star right
burning this bright and right that
distance and it's turning this fast it's
got these chemicals in it right and all
of a sudden the world around you becomes
part of your back your intellectual
backyard
that's very cool so now let's uh let's